Fentanyl is not a new drug, but it has seen a very large increase over the past three years.
It has become a critical crisis in North and South America.
Simply, once touched it may cause an overdose.
So what exactly does he do to your mind and body?
Fentanyl is an opioid that can block pain signals through multiple pathways on the direction of the brain and spinal cord.
For this reason he was dismissed as a dwelling of pain at first.
Your brain can also produce dopamine in larger amounts, causing a strong sense of activity and relaxation.
Essentially, the fentanyl takes away your body building in the endorphine system
By tying opioid receptors, in a way very similar to that of your endorphins.
But at a much stronger level.
This may seem fun, but these active receptors can curb your brain's ability to control the levels of carbon dioxide in your body
It is likely to cause the person to stop breathing.
Furthermore, it affects the side involved on the rotor
Cold, vomiting, fainting, urination and severe constipation.
In addition, fentanyl is much stronger than other violets.
100 times more powerful than morphine and heroin 50 times.
Many drugs need to cross blood barriers in the brain.
These barriers allow small soluble fats to cross, and water-loving molecules can be inhibitory.
Both morphine and heroin are soluble fats, but they have a pole and water-loving groups
This makes them slowly cross the barriers.
While fentanyl is neither a polar nor a soluble solubility, it enters the brain in minutes.
This means that you only need a very small amount to become under influence and there is a hazard at this stage.
A lethal dose of fentanyl, approximately two Almiliqram, two grains of sugar semblance in the test tubes.
While it needs a high level of precision to perform effectively, it is very easy to receive an overdose.
In fact, there are many reported incidents of my future ODing for the first time due to a simple touch of fentanyl powder.
Or inhalation of dust.
However, some toxicologists doubt the accuracy of these cases.
If you can set the time, an individual can give an injection of Nelskone
Which works to stop anesthesia by blocking the receptors of aphids.
But scientists could not keep up with the new fentanyl analogues.
Such as the most potent carvinthenyl ten million times morphine
He noted that it is still likely to be used in chemical warfare.
Today, mortality rates in America are high due to overdose of drugs.
65,000 deaths in 2016 compared to 59,000 in 2015
The use of Avon is the core of the problem.
In context, it is higher than rifle deaths,
Of HIV / AIDS deaths, as well as deaths from motor vehicle accidents.
All evidence indicates a worsening of the problem by the end of 2018.
Reason? Research suggests that the prescriptions for opioids spread to pain, causing addiction.
Also causes rapid access to millions of tablets by non-specialists to dispense drugs to fall into the wrong hands.
As the risk became clearer, doctors reduced the prescription of opiates
But that did not change the fact that thousands of people who were addicted could cause them to look into illegal markets.
As demand mounted, illicit drug markets headed for cheaper solutions.
Unlike the compound of poppy heroin (narcotic plant), it is artificially fentanyl completely and can be manufactured in any place at a cheap price.
China has become a very important nation in the manufacture of fentanyl, and the North American Land Stocking Act operates.
After all, the United Kingdom urges British to find critical solutions to crises in order to convince people not to use opiates.
The ban on Chinese markets could simply lead to the transfer of production to another country.
Many government officials are appealing to the government to protect consumption sites.
Where people with addiction can be monitored, reducing the risk of overdoses.
It can be supported by counseling and anti-addiction drugs, helping people stop using it.
But is it possible that some drugs are good for you?
Translation: team translate Autrjim @